hola bienvenidos a la economía soy
santiago lópez gonzález por mi compañera
daniela plantón comenzamos hablando del
clima para los negocios en américa
latina' que subió en el tercer trimestre
de este año a su mejor nivel en los
últimos tres años y medio según el
indicador medido por el centro brasileño
de estudios económicos fundación getúlio
vargas que consulta trimestralmente a
149 especialistas en 15 países para
calcular su indicador el llamado índice
de clima económico de américa latina
alcanzó 99 puntos 7 puntos su mayor
nivel desde el primer trimestre de 2018
y después de que en 2020 cayera 40.1
puntos por la crisis económica por
supuesto generada por la pandemia de
kobe 19 esta mejora fue impulsada por
países como brasil chile perú y méxico-
que registraron las mayores variaciones
producto del avance de las campañas de
vacunación en la región y también por el
boom de los precios de las materias
primas
el desempleo en sudáfrica llegó a un
nivel récord te podemos decir que es
actualmente la tasa de desempleo más
alta del mundo según la lista que
elabora la agencia bloomberg entre 82
países alrededor del mundo en el top de
este listado aparecen otros países como
namibia nigeria jordania y costa rica en
américa latina' tan sólo en el segundo
trimestre de este año sudáfrica alcanzó
el 34.4 por ciento es decir 7.8 millones
de personas están sin empleo pero
tomando en cuenta la definición ampliada
que incluye a los desanimados en buscar
algún puesto de trabajo la cifra aumenta
a 11.9 millones o el 44.4 por ciento de
la población activa las bajas en el
empleo se ubicaron en sectores como
finanzas que eliminó a 278 mil puestos
de trabajo mientras que los servicios
sociales y también los comunitarios
perdieron 166 mil puestos por su parte
la manufactura perdió 83 mil plazas de
trabajo
y el banco mundial quito la ayuda a
afganistán y aseguró estar muy
preocupado por las mujeres otros
organismos como el fondo monetario
internacional habían ya bloqueado
algunos fondos a este país asiático hace
algunos días el banco mundial dijo estar
monitoreando de cerca la situación en
afganistán que permanece en caos tras él
tras la llegada del talibán el pasado 15
de agosto de nuevo al poder el organismo
tiene en afganistán al menos 20
proyectos de desarrollo recientemente el
fondo monetariointernacional bloqueó el
desembolso de 370 millones de dólares
que tenían aprobados desde el año pasado
pero la incertidumbre política detuvo
todo el apoyo económico
y alemania la mayor economía de europa
creció 1.6 por ciento entre abril y
junio en comparación con el trimestre
anterior el consumo privado y también el
gasto estatal impulsaron una leve
recuperación económica en alemania luego
de una flexibilización de las
restricciones de kobe 19 en ese país del
centro de europa aunque las cifras no
alcanzan la ganancia del 2% que los
economistas pronosticaron por problemas
en la cadena de suministro incluida
también una interrupción de seis días
provocada por un buque que bloqueó el
canal de suez el año pasado y que lo
reportamos aquí en france 24 pese a este
crecimiento el producto interno bruto
alemán fue de 3.3 puntos menor que en el
cuarto trimestre del 2019 antes de la
pandemia de kobe 19
hablamos ahora de los indicadores de las
principales bolsas del mundo comenzamos
con wall street que amplió este martes
las ganancias y terminó registrando
récords en dos de sus principales
indicadores gracias a la aprobación de
la vacuna the fighter by antich en eeuu
en europa por su parte la bolsa de
londres cerró en verde con una subida
promovida por las ganancias generadas y
registradas en los títulos mineros
mientras que en américa latina la bolsa
de comercio de buenos aires en argentina
cerró con una alza por tercera vez
consecutiva
y para el cierre la cifra del día 9
billones de dólares ese ha sido el gasto
de los bancos centrales en eeuu europa y
japón desde el inicio de la pandemia
esto los convierte en los gigantes del
mercado haciendo crecer sus activos
combinados a 24 billones de dólares este
flujo es tan grande que solo la reserva
federal de eeuu podría comprarse un
millón de inmuebles en nueva york' que
de por sí ya es uno de los sectores
inmobiliarios más caros del mundo
es todo por el momento aquí en la
economía en france24 siga con nosotros
[Música]